I come to this video playing Tasmanian
devil but is from Finland okay let's
play a calc on this is going for gathers
weird form of exchange caro-kann with 95
this has become unpopular recently it is
also a line that has been presented in
this secrets of opening surprises the
SOS books and it's interesting yeah I am
but the smooth is new to me I only had I
recently had looked at the slide I only
looked at deform i can go Bishop d7 but
I'm not sure I want to give up the the
bishops so early okay
if my idea was to play e6 and 56 but on
the e6 you might play now we'll create
five queen of three this kind of moves
are sometimes really a problem in this
position but i think i also have quincy
seven of everything else fails okay
Walter should be six okay the idea of
the setup bishop d6 97's to have f6
available and yeah get rid of the snide
it's just a bit slow but it should be
okay for me I mean maybe he has got some
some aggressive moves that that question
the setup like win age fire form Queen
g-form if there's nothing terrible
happening in the next two or three moves
I should be okay the knight on c3 is
also a bit misplaced he would certainly
prefer to to have a pole on c3 and the
night so no maybe I'll did to her three
something like that but okay he needed
to do that basically hmm yeah okay if I
take a five with the bishop and play d4
we can take it due to the pin so let's
unpin now I'm threatening Bishop b5
winning a piece
there should be five g5 default just for
walking and without the pin yeah he's
just ignoring it I mean isn't this
winning a piece i don't i don't see why
not a qui our bishop own nite nite a for
a night a form takes takes d4 Knight a
for not not a very natural looking move
but I can do that okay
night a form yeah I don't really have a
great move laughter that can go to again
go to a c7
yeah I mean I probably should still do
it the question is to see seven or eight
five six seven a taxi five at least I go
on a five in my play Bishop b2 gaining a
temple so I better better just retreat
yeah if it takes d4 now i have worked
the ages one booth after which she needs
to play C 3 I can also just take it it's
got this we at night on a form
yeah I probably should take on d4 I
think the drug the age group the HC
three really really looks uncomfortable
also have a six maybe spend more time on
that
or just night f5 yeah come on let's do
that d 4 is a tech now again if you take
c6 Queen tags I attack this unlucky
night on c5 yeah this looks okay I must
be I must be cautious with a move like a
six because b6 is terribly weakened so
we might have any have to have replies
with putting something on b6 what is he
doing now yeah I can just take it take
with with the rook maybe I guess what
Queen z3m not helping much okay let's
let's consider a 6m think yeah it should
be six I can just take the three at the
end that's before they
and night night be 60 not working at all
i think i can play with the age of
everything else fails maybe there's
something better even but it should be
ok if you takes Queen takes the night is
hanging and it doesn't have fun great
great possibilities be three maybe to go
to see five after be five they have an
ID be six ok I can also take here yeah
that's really what IAM take be five
night takes and queen a five the salmon
brook d4 Knight a a truck takes d3 right
see sambrook t1 hun that's also that's
also possible what taking night a8 Queen
a five should be 6 53 Chevy if I rook t1
and made at the Antonine this is Sir
this is tricky I don't I dare I cannot
take here right but there will be five
is also hanging
ok
a bishop physics actually had had seen
this line and why am i playing it I had
seen that this is a background made at
the end and still I ignored it why this
is silly oh come on yeah I had actually
seen that night takes a five is not on
now and still I I went for it Oh idiotic
is dead okay yeah now this is even to
rapture what the heck does this time
morning oh this is very not sound yeah
not a good start to the session i
completely forgot i had seen it I think
I could win on time is very slow draw
our third game Tehran nice very slow so
you have what how sick is that I saw
this I saw the line but I still I still
went for it mhm ya i ti should I short I
really have a good good continuation
maybe just drooped the aerial the
computers has white is ok here which I
have a hard time to believe but maybe
maybe a six was really bad yeah of
course it is bad I can I must just
switch switch the move on and black is
flat-out winning yeah this is stupid
this is just trapped now I mean add the
idea but of course I should should take
first yeah well this is this is very
simple we can try try that move but
let's even this reply trapping this yeah
and now we had to add this this is
smooth I should probably just play route
piayed something like that is certainly
playable for black it's not grade or
anything but okay I think something like
that that have a good diagonal his spawn
is not worth so much at the moment I
have a very stupid and I saw this I mean
I mentioned it in the in the comments
yeah and this is just dead now I mean is
in addition this is it is it I'm
probably losing losing this piece as
well wow wow this was terrible thanks
for watching anyway